we are like what are we like two weeks
in one day away from the start of the
NFL season eagles falcons I might be
going to the game oh yeah you don't
let's start there
yeah we're getting everything right I
need your advice I haven't brought this
up to you about my like issue with this
yeah so my brother was the only one of
my immediate family that wasn't there
for the Super Bowl right and I still
feel bad about it why why did I didn't
have control because my my dad was able
to get two tickets and he had to split
the guy had season tickets with and my
mom wanted to go so I got her so I I
couldn't get him to the game okay he was
the only one that didn't get to go right
my dad asked me to go to the season
opener against the Falcons yeah I know
that my brother wants to go I just have
a feeling right and I feel like I would
be bad taking that from him because but
I also know that I have not been able to
go to a regular-season game with my dad
in wait so if you go he can't go
probably not I can't you just never gone
to a regular-season game because we're
always working on Sunday and this is a
Thursday game right so I'm torn so we're
gonna start the podcast there I guess I
don't know you get a third ticket it's
gonna be this the home opener with like
the Super Bowl and it's season tickets
like my dad has his to ticket right son
let your brother go yes
I think that's pretty I mean you need to
go to the Super verse all we have work
that day on Thursday so what are you
gonna rush there leave right out yeah
sure
okay great just don't try to give it up
get a medium give it to baby bear Jew
and let him sit there and enjoy my day
my dad's like I've never got to watch a
regular slice I didn't it to watch the
Super Bowl with my dad either right I
watched my mom okay can't have it all
you know Kevin was really good at
leaving the office quickly and
efficiently what he's done working not
left go
no no crap he has to say goodbye to
every single person on the way out the
door believe it for you leave at 5:30
because you talked to 47 people
my girlfriend was saying this that you
know there are people that Irish goodbye
right and then I think what I do is a
Jewish good way you just
everybody's like 45 minutes of like
maybe we should get to our drinks okay
bagels so next Wednesday is going to be
our big season awards division please
remind me of that okay yes so you
haven't formalized anything no I mean I
have a few rough outlines in my head I
just don't in the AFC hadrian so that's
a preview for next ones
there was a thread on the reddit page of
some people that went back and listened
to last year's season predictions
episode yeah and it was not pretty it
was not ready well it's got the Saints
yeah he also did not get the Giants Oh
someone put it on right so NFC East you
guys both pick the Giants NFC North you
both pick the Vikings right we both
correct the south I went bucks he went
Saints yep and if say West both went
Seahawks so we got that wrong wild card
left go went Cardinals and Packers and
Hill Sims went Cardinals and Cowboys I
forgot the Cardinals we're supposed to
be really good last year it's a liar you
guys want the AFC yeah so AFC E's good
self scouting both Patriots right AFC
North left go un Steeler Sims you went
Ravens oh well I was right if see South
both Titans a AFC West we got that wrong
yep Jacksonville Jacksonville won the
division in the West left go un Chiefs
Sims you went Raiders and then wild-card
won the West
the Chiefs so wild cards left go you
went Broncos and Dolphins Sims you went
Broncos and Steelers the Steelers
Steelers got in pick so overall records
left go you were four and eight seems
you were three and nine Alonso and why
did point out that Adams said I think
people are sleeping on the Eagles right
now there you go I did say that and then
I know MVP you went Brady I did and I
went Russell Wilson know you went well I
was Lady did you know I got Brady to
write Defensive Player of the Year t
should have been third you picked Von
Miller I did and I picked daniil hunter
who I'm not gonna lie in my short list
of possible Defensive Player of the Year
candidate back on there made the list I
think yeah but there's no way I'm
picking him
I looked really good some of the
division pics are ready are stressing me
out just about the NFC is where I'm just
some like I'm scared to death yes the
NFC East I genuinely have no idea about
the NFC North I'm going one of three
ways the NFC West they really don't have
any idea
NFC South is a little clearer to me but
the AFC South who's one of the AFC South
Jacksonville Tennessee or Houston could
be could be any of the three the West no
idea no idea
I think the Chargers are gonna win the
West okay but I feel actually really
good about that well you know what made
me question that and we're gonna get
into this even do it all now but like
when I were learned that Roberto Aguayo
was gonna be their kicker this year
right my first thought was like I could
totally see him blowing - game yeah
totally see no give him a cake sorry ok
ok I don't you know great kicker no I
don't great I did it I did a radio
interview remember Serina that we met
out there she was hosting serious last
night I went on and they were like
talking about bortles and they're like
is this like a thing with Simms I said
when he was drafted Sims gave him an F
right at 3 not him but the Jag Rice this
has not been a creation that has been
yes life yes I want to give a shout out
to the Sims and Lefko fans the SL FL the
fantasy league has already begun
they've been drafting pretty much
throughout the week our draft is next
Tuesday next to the golden spleen
conference
Oh del Rodgers is that what we're gonna
give me another name then let's shut the
hell up both you ok shut the hell up are
you gonna draft with us uh I'll be a
adviser it's like you you're gonna hire
me as tight guys I think I wanna
FaceTime Sims for each pic and we'll
record his advice and then just post
that and you and I will be together and
make the paper yeah cuz I've done like
500 mock drafts at this point right it's
disgusting it's a really a disease
you've a bit of a problem it's because
it's just fun I think doing the dress is
more fun than actually playing fantasy
football because you're going like ooh
like my gonna get on the 11th pick and
one of my friends leaks right and like
DeAndre Hopkins fell to me the other day
and I was
this is incredible like I'm sending it
to my friends like it matters and it
doesn't matter
we had a guy tweeting at us over in
London as he was doing his draft at
12:15 in the morning and had to be up at
work for work at 5:00 a.m. and he said
the draft finish at 3:00 a.m. but he
stayed up to do it yeah whoa big
offseason conference I believe it was
golf season conference thanks
so we have at least one representative
for every team for the F the play up
what is it correspondence some of them
were asking a little bit of
clarification right what they should be
looking okay yes so I have a few
questions and then I want you to just
kind of go in - okay cool our sax
included in the f the play up statistics
no I mean there are no we're not gonna
count that because the tackles for loss
sure what if you're one of the guys it's
like a part of a sack but you don't get
credit for it
well then what do you mean he's not a
part of the sack then he should have got
a credit for it so it was the play up a
week if a guy bust through the line of
scrimmage all right let's just say it's
Fletcher Cox he bustard the line of
scrimmage and has one arm on the
quarterback and the cornerback wiggled
through but it had to also step up like
four yards in the pocket and then his
sacked by somebody else no that's the
that's F the play off let your [ __ ]
what is lecture class bust through the
line right quarterback escapes rolls out
then frozen incomplete pass yeah it's at
the plate yeah [ __ ] bust through the
line gets a hand on him but the guy
steps up like deshaun Watson and
completes the pass he still left the
play doubt he have to play it at play up
he did he did more than what he was
statistically asked to do you kid we're
not gonna sit there and judge now the
greatness of deshaun Watson and say well
do Shawn got out of that and threw a
completion four yards in the flat no the
play was sorry for this we're [ __ ] up
already
we just there's a more than one great
player on the field the NFL there's not
you know so your your definition really
is is typically a defensive lineman or a
linebacker I guess it could be anybody
sometimes that gets through the design
of the play offensively they've ruined
the design now yeah you run rod right
what's an edge rusher
right surround right a quarterback
simply steps up that's not enough
that's just normal that's that's an edge
rusher gumming around the edge and the
corner back yes now if the edge rusher
comes around the edge and just
absolutely pile drives the offense a
tackle into the quarterback and now the
whole pockets messed up and even the
quarterback escaped somehow yes and then
throws another completion he F the play
up he's gonna get a big-time positive
grade from his coach like there was a
Myles Garrett play where he backed the
left tackle into the quarterback and in
the quarterback then threw an incomplete
pass exactly
huge F at the play up exactly right gosh
so this is that sacks don't tell the
full story right and we want people to
be looking for players who have
negatively affected the offenses
intentions was actually something that
they've exactly right I mean Fletcher
Cox could be playing the Rams
and he could F the play up and go what
day and he busted through the line of
scrimmage and had Todd Gurley with two
hands seven yards behind the line of
scrimmage and then Todd Gurley somehow
broke that tackle and ran for a 70 yard
touchdown
it doesn't matter Fletcher Cox still he
have to play up man he have to play up
it's just again where were the other
guys to come and help them and then Todd
Gurley is the amazing town so I'm
watching Hard Knocks last night yeah
oh it's typical where you go I gotta
watch it I didn't watch that I never
liked their last week Nate orchard had
like three plays including the Josh
Allen touchdown right where he got there
and Josh young so in your mind but like
this is where it gets tricky yeah Nate
Jordan 8 orchard was like unblocked on
that one yeah that's not that's not like
effing so that's a detail for it is a
detail it's a free rusher if they're
going up to the quarterback that's not
enough to play out right you need to
blow for a block right or make a guy
miss it can't just be clear off the edge
oh we missed the sack no you know the
resilient block layup I would yes I
would argue there that no the
quarterback of the offense says F the
protection up there in that show if
someone is a free runner you could not
be included as enough to play oh no
that's not enough to play out ok so our
definition of f the play up is you go
through around over-under like offensive
lineman or running back trying to block
and negatively impact the play whether
it's a run pay or player pass right
including if you bust through the
offensive line and the running back has
to go
wider to the outside after that counts -
yes but a handle no doubt let's just say
Jamal Adams for the Jets they're playing
let's just say the Jacksonville Jaguars
he's down at the line of scrimmage man
the C gap has a huge hole and all the
sudden Jamal Adams is there before
Leonard fournette can even get to the
hole oh and now he has to stop
redirect go outside no Jamal Adams just
he screwed the play up he shot his gun
and he flew through there to where it
got ruined
yes and our point is this if you make
the sack you're not eligible if you make
the tackle you're not eligible right
we're trying to give credit to the guys
that get lost in the history of the NFL
because there's no stat that led to
someone else getting the sacrament Akal
or an incomplete passer and you know
what our biggest thing is yeah if you
caused an intentional grounding sure you
get a [ __ ] to play oh no doubt about
because that's the most egregious thing
that's not counting the NFL if you
should get a sack that's so stupid
you're right I feel like that should get
an fft pu+ if you cause the intentional
grounding I would like to be the podcast
for the show that keeps track of that
one for sure
causing intentional grounding is
applause just for all those people out
there - this is these are the guys that
offensive coordinators are worried about
like like again going back to 2014 Super
Bowl xlix right
Patriots Seahawks we saw those until he
said Patriots Seahawks did you know what
he was talking I had no clue - we saw
the preparation the Patriots did for the
Seahawks and that's superb that wasn't
2014 I was 2014 feels like that was
there we go with Michael Bennett this is
where we started on this whole thing I
think Michael Bendis the reason we
started this conversation
it's that Super Bowl he should have been
MVP he was he was the best player Indy
on the NFL for like a three or four year
span and that week when you look back in
I can't remember what the damn show was
but whatever whatever that show was that
was following the Patriots a year hey
all those great defensive players on the
Seattle Seahawks the Patriots were
worried about Michael Bennett more than
anybody that's all they cared about is
that nearly as good as Richard Sherman's
or Cam Chancellor's or Bobbie Wagner's
the bottom line stat line was not on
their level but I promise you when
people watch them
broke down the Seahawks the number one
guy they worried about in game plan for
was number 72 Michael Bennett we are
tired of the big ugly's not kidding
[ __ ] right that's really what it comes
down to all right so I was talking about
Hard Knocks a little bit ago there is a
moment from last night's show that has
kind of begin sweeping a little bit and
it's going a little bit viral so that
show comes on a Tuesday night who's a
nice okay so I've been catching in the
Wednesday rerun Oh
so Nick I'm gonna play right here I
thought I came out on Sundays I didn't
even realize here is the offensive line
coach for the brown right talking about
his least favorite part of practice and
by the way this is the kind of guy that
when he says hike his entire man chest
and belly goes up like he's built like
you'll see World War 1 World War 2 all
those guys that fall in that war right
they did push-ups jumping jacks sit-up
to climb to up and ran but none of this
fancy stop Tommy that right there this
pause at first second first of all he's
so right the stretching is you're so
crazy I know stretching stretching the
more if you get to know high end really
high end training the thing they're
finding out more in the world that
anything first of all it is overrated
like the greatest some of the greatest
players I've ever seen Michael Vick I
could promise you when I watched him in
pregame warmups everybody was stretching
and he was standing there scratching his
ear and looking at the stadium stretch
why are you I know you've heard this
from me before and I'm gonna say it
anyways but this is what they're finding
out like why would you over stretch
muscles when you're gonna go ten minutes
later I want you to be really tight and
explosive right that's what players are
messing out on and I know what he's
saying
like the stretching part now all you
need to do is warm up stretching is an
after workout exercise people need to
this is the new age listen to what I say
or you will pay okay down to the bag
yeah go ahead sorry to world wars
two world wars like the one jumping
jacks push-ups and sit-ups two world
wars you think they were worried when
they're running a course Normandy about
[ __ ] stretching are you kidding me
let me see give me my rubber band so I
can stretch the run cross that [ __ ]
beat you gotta be kidding me
he's amazing that's all i'ma know this
guy drives a Maserati a white Maserati
he did it's in it it's it's not one of
the tiny tiny ones custom the mid-level
ones so you're telling me that everyone
online is going look at this guy saying
stretchings crazy what a typical ol lyin
rant yeah and of course you're the only
one that agrees you're any wall
stretching yes you've said this to me
for a very long time really I think if
you look at a lot of high-level athletes
first of all they go through what they
call the wily is the coach Bob Wiley yes
active dynamic warm up right so you get
everything going warm you get it all
firing why if you're why would you pull
on your hamstrings and your quads and go
get loose and get long and in five
minutes I want you to be really quick
and explosive it makes no sense that's
how injuries happen that's want it to be
like a rubber band great things about -
you want it to be ready to fire and go
you want it to twitchiness to be at its
twitch iasts you know that it cannot
possibly be and how can you be twitchy
if you're telling it to stretch and
relax I mean you might want on rants to
me about how the foam roller rolling
that's the dumbest thing to do before a
work the dumbest thing there you want to
smooth out your muscles most of us and
I'm including me and you guys are
certainly in this oh we're not explosive
enough I don't care if we stretch for
nine hours before you're not explosive
enough to pull something so it doesn't
matter to you or you know Joey work out
at the equinox and matters like that but
people like Odell Beckham jr. or Julio
Jones if they're sitting there like oh
let me pull down so hard and stretch my
hamstrings to where it almost feels like
it's gonna pop and my lower back is
gonna pop yeah it feels like that cuz
the shit's gonna pop if you pull any
farther you're making so far yes so
you've always said that the really best
athletes wide receivers whether it's the
Ochocinco Zoar anybody just you look at
their calves and it's this tiny
little muscle right but it's so tight
packed that it just explodes and then if
you look at someone like myself right I
have very large cast as a giant calf I
have a huge cache it's useless doesn't
do anything for you but a lot of people
are depressed so here these athletes
have these tiny little cat I never
stretched right so you agree with Bob
Wiley a little bit I mean yes I mean
listen two world wars they won two world
wars yeah it's like it's like stretching
is like let's think about the ninth guy
and we never see the ninth guy off the
bench who like hasn't played three
quarters in the NBA game he doesn't come
out and pull his mutton pull any muscles
it's it's like it's just part of the
routine no if you want to get warm do
little things like butt kicks that I'll
get your quad strength of a good bus
great leg run to get the hamstring fire
to me you do high knees exactly right
well josh has some like athlete's calves
that just ends there that's the only
problem even as doctor said so my
trainer excused yes why not my train I
had a free bounding session he kept
saying as a trainer and so you are
you're already calling him your trainer
even though I was the free trade it was
yeah it was you know how when you join
the gym you into signing up now he said
whatever you want to do let me know and
I said you keep complimenting my calves
like that I'll be back does he have good
lower body muscle density his calves yes
I don't know I do not agree with the
rest of that lower body well that's why
I said relax in the text messages your
quads and badunkadunk I got good glutes
I don't know about that I got real good
glutes short this offensive line coach
Bob Wiley though in one of the next
scenes I showed his team animals that
he'd like them to be like he's very I
love it he showed a warthog and how wide
they were it's impossible to draw face
he showed a rhinoceros and then he
showed like a silverback gorilla and he
said this is you guys he goes really
long arms always walks with knees bent
right and the ovens line was loving it
but I'm like damn this the [ __ ] that
Sims talks about all the time Bob Wiley
on a pocket I would love to o Lyman like
that old line coaches like that but it
would be gold because he's not
Bob while he's those guys are not
worried either about anything they're
really not they're willing to kind of
stay in their Lane and talk about their
guys the way they want to talk about him
and they'll say crap where you'll be
like whoa that's kind of funny
literally after he shows the gorilla it
goes and his face kind of looks like my
ex-mother-in-law like that was his next
loss yeah I love that guy Dez Bryant
I'll write his name down yeah Bob Wiley
Dez Bryant was also featured very
prominently on the show going around and
saying hi to everybody like to the point
where it was almost like wreaked of
desperation already apparently Dez
didn't like your Sims and 60s and I'm
gonna add this note yeah
I was very surprised by your Sims and
sixth right Josh already came at you
this morning and you were defending yes
so what was your Sims in 60 right Sims
in 60 first of all it's just like food
for thought right that's that's what it
is to me it's about bringing up angles
that I notice in football that people
don't talk about and it's under the
radar and it needs to be brought to
these guys when I see things on the
Internet yeah I think everything's that
take right so your opinion that you were
trying to show people was if you look at
the Patriots they never pay a guy like
an Aaron Donald or a Khalil Mac too much
of their salary exactly they're not
gonna give 70 80 million dollars to
somebody 30% of their cap to one guy
that's just not how they work right not
even Tom Brady not Gronk not Dante
Hightower not Malcolm Butler nobody
everybody because your point was if they
get hurt 30% of your salary cap is down
the juggler Bill Belichick looks at it
and goes man for that 30% I could have
got three other guys at that position
now I kind of saw it yeah and then Dez
solid right so what it does say let's go
to our Dez reader yeah Josh vendrick's
first of all good job way to be on
Instagram very good staff mix all right
so Dez left that one Dez left a couple
comments first comment Bill Belichick's
strategy is one in a million that was
the first thing he said I think we can
all agree on that next comment a little
bit longer yeah that's easy for everyone
to agree on because they will never see
that kind of money but check this don't
forget why everyone watches football
because of the players the end of
created that money cap at the same time
it generates so much money from us
players and we have to fight to get at
least five percent out of a hundred of
what we generate I bet we don't see ten
percent as a whole we all would be lucky
to see half the contract after we sign
so please don't be blinded by these
foolish contracts it's only a few who
got fully guaranteed deals Uncle Sam is
going to get his Mac and Donald are
rightfully owed whatever they are asking
just like Odell it's always a problem
whenever it's time to do business these
are all things we agree with no doubt
about it that's that's I'm not see
that's where I'm not I'm not arguing
that that's that's I know you agree with
him I want the players to be paid you're
just saying I'm just showing that
there's a team that's dominated football
for the last 18 years and this is the
route they have taken other than a de
leus Thomas which they learned from
because they gave him a whole lot of
money and it ended up being a bust other
than that you can't find a Patriots
player that was paid like an errand
Donald or Coloma not even Tom Brady not
even Tom Brady Tom has just gotten
leverage the last few years finally
really and like I've yes so tom was
famous for settling for less and not
doing anything that's gonna hurt so
first of all I want to respond to dis
Bryant like can we do that video right
now and be like I want to be like first
of all Dez I'm my issue here this is my
point first of all more than anything
it's too skewed to the top end players
my point would be Dez Bryant is not 20
times worse than Odell Beckham jr. mmm
that's what I'm saying that's the
problem in the whole thing oh there
needs to be a closer gap a little bit to
the so-called average or barely above
average player he should be paid a
little bit more and some of the stars
should be paid a little bit less than
what their be paying so what about like
an herb or Ahnold right so Aaron Donald
he's the best of his position in the
sport I get that but at the same time
let's just say let's just take another
good d-tackle that's out there in the
world I mean like average yeah or just
let's go bow Alan yeah okay right he's
not Alan Tampa Bay Bucs he's not he
not I got 12 times better than bow out
or like Coolio Mac like I said with
Bruce Irvin you guys heard me say this
before
Khalil Mack is not five times better
than Bruce Irvin like but his contracts
gonna say that okay so that would be my
issue and I'm all for the players being
paid but I was just making the point
that this is what the Patriots do and
it's what part of why they've been
successful on tour now yeah because I'm
torn because what you're saying makes
sense but I also want these guys to get
I need and we've been fighting for the
elite to get paid more so that it brings
up the salaries for everybody else now
you're making it seem like when they get
paid that much it prevents from
everybody else from getting paid it does
I mean just think that I'll see you I
can't look him in the eye right Odell
Beckham right and say you shouldn't get
the maximum that you're willing no I
want them to get the maximum I do I
really do it's not about that again
again I was just trying to say this is
what the Patriots done and it's a very
effective formula and I think it gets
lost in translation at times I wish
everybody would get paid more money and
get guaranteed contracts that's not what
I'm against but yes I was just trying to
show that side of the business because I
don't think that gets talked about with
the dynasty of the Patriots enough and
yes I guess what I'm basically is saying
is yes some of these top-end players who
are getting 30% of the salary cap
they're not 30 times better than some of
the other guys who were making a million
or two million dollars a year beau Allen
has a three year three year fifteen
million dollar deal right five-minute a
year so Khalil Mac's gonna I mean
they're talking 20 million dollars right
I mean really so it's gonna be a 20
million dollar average something along
those four times better or Aaron Donald
four times a little different position a
four times better
Aaron Donald might be them bow a bow
Allen wasn't the perfect example because
he's more of like a nose tackle you know
what I mean I got all the details here
but yeah let's see let's see some other
ones yeah okay so wait what's somebody
like yeah like okay Geno Atkins is gonna
make what 10 million this year he's
gonna make 10 million average salary is
basically and we're talking about guys
like Aaron down I got a 20 million
average guy like like Aaron Donald's not
two times better than Geno Atkins he's
better but he's not twice
good like dam then holy cow he's amazing
then he's the greatest player ever like
me do you know how can just really been
good he's awesome he's gonna be a
first-ballot hall-of-famer but all I'm
saying is that's where it's skewed a
little bit that was my point
I know should I explain that well I just
just welcome to the world of the
internet that I know where like you put
it up there about salaries people like
no pay though the money and then other
people like don't pay about anything and
it's just it just becomes this echo
chamber of you will respond to DES after
the pocket okay good I want to find you
because I don't want them to think I'm
not formed yet yeah that probably
doesn't he probably thinks it's Matt
Simms speaking of older guys coming back
Adrian Peterson somebody a bleacher bore
can I get a t-shirt somebody give me a
frickin t-shirt like the gemenese only
Mike he was only my coach they give it
to you t-shirts you know we didn't do at
the top of this podcast talk about the
new logo it's official when this comes
out we will have a new logo wow you
talked about it well we got a new title
at the end yeah let's say for the
explain a little bit of what's going on
the end Josh vendrick's gonna talk a lot
at all the big effort in nine minutes
perfect okay Adrian Peterson back with
Washington and you had I saw at least
three to four people come up to in the
office for fantasy reasons going Adrian
Peterson what do you think what do you
think and your responses he's done he's
old it's washed and it's over Adrian
Peterson said to those doubting him it
shows me people don't really know about
football
that's his quote I feel that people that
know the game of football know different
situations a player might be and so when
people go back and say oh two point four
yards per carry there's a lot that
contributes to that and I just brush it
off definitely I mean yeah he's right
about that but he's not the same guy he
was I mean can any great player ever
just freaking admit that they're not the
same guy in year 14 as they are in year
four but that's what makes him crazy I
get it he so he can contribute to their
football team he will he's gonna be part
of the rotation but like he's not gonna
like take over the league and rush for
1,300 yards
I think he's you're like perfect number
two to three ish type of back and so he
joins semaj P Ryan and Robb Kelly right
I mean Chris Thompson's the best running
back on that roster now when he gets
healthy he's the man he
the best player in their offense
arguably last year so he would be the
guy I watch out for but he can certainly
add value to that group semaj Pierre on
does it looks like it was a high ankle
sprain he could be out for a little bit
yeah
he can get carries and I'll say this
he's gonna look as good or better than
last year I can right away because their
offense is better
they have receivers and they have a very
good offensive line the Washington
Redskins yes better than the Cardinals
head line way better than the car so
then ranked the for Washington running
backs Chris Thompson is one I would
probably go pee Rhine to and then a
three-way it's like a tie
mmm it's close between Robb Kelly and ap
are you making Adrian Peterson the the
four third is giving a third yeah he's
third I think yeah so Adrian Peterson is
a third best running back on washing
right if there's a reason nobody in
football's wanted them does everybody
does everybody hear that
okay so what just because he gets like
so now oh we signed he's back to the
best in football yeah but then again
like Adrian Peterson it makes sense but
like there are reasons that Dez is not
signed and I don't think it's because
he's bad like I think Dez has much more
of the tank than Adrian Peterson yes no
I think Dez that some of the off the
field stuff and I always will go back to
the fact that he wasn't used in a
variety of ways with the Cowboys and I
think that's scary Dez ends up on a team
I do definitely who's your pick down um
mmm that's a good question I'm still
rooting for the bengals you think the
bangles would be the one yeah cuz what
have I seen from John Ross that makes me
go oh he's a number two yeah I hear that
I mean you're right it's it's he looks
fast but that's about all he looks mmm
who would he go to Carolina Carolina and
I don't even know if they need him at
this point you know that I would look at
them but I still think the Browns have a
big chance to do it why wouldn't the
Cardinals or the Seahawks get involved
tomorrow's great really lacking you know
especially if Baldwin's not ready to go
week one Cardinals odor on Brown does
look like heart and so does that
Stringfellow the kid from Mississauga
Brown is on Seattle and so Stringfellow
I know yes and they look the part so I'm
just saying he serves on the Cardinals
I'm sorry no Jerome Brown did look good
yeah I got to think about the dead thing
about George Iloka possibly signing with
the Vikings yes okay I get that
you know I look it's funny he started
the game the other day right yes and
then the second bring right in Bates
Bates right in I don't know what
happened there does she get pissed off
and go to the front office or Melvin
Lewis the next day and go like that's
some bolt whatever I don't know but he's
still starting caliber ish safe yeah
he's gonna be great in here better than
Andrews and dae-ho yeah he's in the
writer right along with them they're
gonna battle it out I just I like the
notion of having a guy like that on your
roster if you want to throw three
safeties out there yeah they got corners
too like the Vikings are just they got
really good guys really good corner oh
so this is a clip from Doug Peterson's
book he does in his new book is called
fearless and he says that he was
watching the Patriots Jaguars game yeah
in the locker room before when the
Eagles played the Vikings and when the
Jaguars took a knee at the end of the
first half he said I was there thinking
you've got to be kidding me right now it
made me mad because Jacksonville had New
England right where they wanted them I
was screaming at the TV in my office
very similar to how you and I were
screaming when they knelt right before
half-time inside I was like I'll never
do that it fueled me Peterson said they
could have at least tried for a field
goal they took it out of their
quarterbacks hands and they didn't give
it back to their big back Leonard
fournette
I thought if they lose this game this is
why and sure enough they go on to lose
this game the Eagles got the ball with
29 seconds left in the first half with
three timeouts against the Patriots in
the Super Bowl completed three passes
got a field goal that's how I wanted to
play the last one in the first half with
an aggressive mentality yeah Doug
Marrone came out and said it didn't
bother right but it's great it shouldn't
bother him I mean good for him it's it's
not it's not about him personally you
know if he's coaching his football team
I mean that's how they adopt like the
fact the public thought yeah that this
was a Doug Marrone insult right and it's
not a bortles insult right
Marone is trying to minimize issues he's
he was himself not afraid he wasn't like
Oh ma'am afraid the Patriots gonna do
some no he was afraid his quarter
was going to do something exactly right
I want to show you a picture and I want
to get your reaction to it
okay I'm hungry whoa whoa I love Tigers
okay so this is Baker made well with his
shirt off in front of what looks to be a
Rolls Royce next to a Bengal tiger what
is he doing here he is advertising a
pair of underwear him and a number of
other athletes have their own like
tights that you would wear to the gym
right and this what is your take on just
the picture I mean it's it's actually a
cool picture it's not something you see
a quarterback do all the time so I give
him kudos to that
that's a whoa big preseason it is I mean
again I don't think I would do that I
just tell me not until at least I've
like gone to the playoffs it is an upset
a lot of the traditional media
I'm sure Colin Cowherd all those guys
you have been done anything Zac what do
you doing taking a picture it's gonna
rub people in his locker room the wrong
way I mean is it really yeah to a degree
they're not gonna be okay Baker what the
hell you doing but they're gonna be like
oh they're gonna be like yo this is
predictable there's gonna be no there's
gonna be some guys in the corner locker
room being like man what's he doing so
you're not allowed to do any
advertisements are you the starter yet
yeah I'm exactly I mean what's he done
has he helped Cleveland win a game yet
no so that's that's so I know it's a
tough thing because guys had to get
their money all celebrated Patrick
mahomes last year because he turned down
all advertisement dollars because he
didn't think he was there yet right so
that's what everyone's supposed to do
it's kind of just the old-school
unwritten rule you don't have to do it
but you know it's just yeah there's
gonna be a you just got to realize that
when you do that you're certain guys who
judge people in the locker room which
there's always that guy in life or in a
locker room like they're gonna judge you
and as soon as he throws an interception
like I promise you they're those same
guys are gonna be the ones and lock in
the go if maybe if you had a shirt on to
that area you know whatever is it
different with quarterbacks what if say
Quan did this say Quan could probably
get away with it yeah the quarterback it
is different Thursday why because he's
like attention he's got all the
attention as it is he gets every benefit
of the doubt in the world and now he
hasn't done anything to help the team
and he's gonna get capitalize off that
even more so that's where it just
drives people crazy it really is a
quarterback by there's a quarterback
bias let's bring in the best quarterback
in the history of the New York Giants
okay let's bring it all right so let's
call Phil Simms you know Phil Simms is
like apparently going around and telling
people about my wiffle ball stuff yeah
well I saw the thews EO thing yes yes
he's going around and telling people
that I almost broke at my back and that
but I was I was surprisingly athletic
that story of my life
surprisingly athletic hello hello hello
quiet
hey hey who are you talking to somebody
very important yeah we were just
listening in when I hear what you guys
are talking tell us who well I can't but
I'll fill you in later than you can
secretly tell Adam later okay who's he
the head coach of the Patriots yeah no I
don't think Bill Belichick so call me
but it was a lot of good stuff I and
Wootton
it was like damn I'm glad you guys are
late well you're not as late as usual
and you heard because you hear them
talking on the phone as I was no no
because good good we would have known
who it was you're saying well I don't
know if you would have not but it
doesn't matter the information was
tremendous
and I'm saturating tremendous Phil I I
go online today and I see a video of you
telling people about my softball
performance you're just kind of spilling
all the secrets huh what wouldn't I do
that it was that a thoose eyo event
apparently you were saying that I almost
broke my back but I was surprised I have
letter well you gotta admit your first
swing was like you know you were so
frigging nervous you yeah whatever I got
to be careful even on your podcast
you're so nervous and bike you know come
on just relax and hit the damn thing
he's the only guy
right it was like a cartoon you could
have buried yourself in the ground you
just twist it into the ground it was
great right and I've never seen anybody
swing that hard - and he in a wiffle
ball game he kept both hands on the bat
like the whole swing right like who does
that novo football game like full
throttle professional swing well I don't
I'm not ken griffey jr. but you know
yeah I know I look I just gotta be
honest you're I knew you were someone
that you were much more athletic than I
thought and of course I won't get to see
these things I'd like to you know if I
still could do it play your little hoops
and just see what kind of game you had
that kind of stuff I was a little bit
more I would love to that we'll get a
game of hoops you'll play phen jerk and
he's done oops really that's a disaster
wait oh let me make this move or this or
that all blew my Achilles hurt money
yeah yeah it's just what I want in life
right now I don't have enough going on
at your peak which NBA players game was
similar to yours the most none know who
you you seem like he's uh he's kind of
got like a double-handed jump shot yeah
what he does he's so dad's lefty and he
throws righty and he writes lefty and he
I put it yeah he's got some little
issues there go hunt with my left hand
- when I was boxing everybody already
knew that so yeah I mean he was like
he's having a check he was Larry legend
ish yeah yeah yes Larry Bird yes yeah
it's like that it's kind of you're gonna
come out here and compare yourself to
Larry look I'm doing it from a you know
a weekend warrior nice not from that
standpoint and I could box out up
friggin dump truck box them out for
rebounds I don't care how much you could
just get did I ask on you and you're not
gonna go over the top of me
so you had a good you had a good shot or
were you mainly like a no you had a very
good shot yeah we would we played a lot
of Hoops in the summer time as your pro
player comparison Chris LeBron and Jay
so do this Christopher I forgot were
your the seven three three
Christopher I think I was eighth grade
but yeah I was good at basketball he was
growing up yeah but he one day we'd
always play and I'd always I didn't keep
it closer then I'd close the game out
and kick his assets in and then one day
we're out there to driveway and okay
he's up I'm let him up seven at three we
played all 11 baskets and that's okay
now kick his ass and all of a sudden I
go damn I lost 11 to 5 what the hell I
was cold now I'm serious I'm gonna I'm
gonna skulk him and then he just he
really beats my ass I went okay that's
over it was a great day I never beat him
in another game we played the rest of
our life I always say about his high
school basketball career he was a very
good freshman player he was good as
assault very good as a sophomore too you
know in a very strict game or whatever
but what do you want I don't know I'm
not gonna say you went downhill but you
know Christopher you he didn't play
basketball all he was alone a summer I'm
gonna go play in the basketball leagues
and do all this no you're not doing that
crap yeah
you're not playing basketball in college
I'm not you know I just yeah I was just
not gonna let him do it yeah I had
people yes they were trying to make me
do both there for a little boy yeah my
like my car my high school basketball
coach thought I could go to college and
be like a double sport player realize I
killed Greg Paulus yeah hey look hey
Ramapo College was near our house here
near Division three okay now here's one
of his teammates when a parent played
Kevin Stokes yes and I'd go up there and
watch him every once awhile and I'd go
Wow look at these kids and I go this is
Division three right you know there were
guys from Bob Hurley st. Anthony's teams
playing guard listening just going these
are Division three right so what did
Division One players look like getting
really close and see them so they're
incredible yeah they're incredible I
mean it's it's uh well it's it's a
football you've got lots of different
ways you could have success you know you
can just be one thing and you can put
the basketball I don't know that one
thing guy that
days over to me and it has got to be
able to do it all right so Phil you know
that we have Steve Rosner going to be a
special Friday episode really yeah
we talked to him he was great man did he
tell embarrassing stories about you know
he would never do that
oh you've already had about that
shipment you're gonna have miss Friday
so it's gonna come another man Friday
but we did it all me what did he tell
you everything and his life and why he
is successful and everything is for just
one reason is because of Boomer Esiason
no he did not say that on credit
lawrence taylor career i brought all the
players to you you did indeed be getting
the cut and he'll you don't get me
enough commercials and no no and you
know no he credited lawrence a lot yeah
well I remember Steve being around the
locker room and having lawrence as a
client i guess it was probably his first
one one of the worst one of his first
definitely that's what he said i didn't
realize it was one of his mercy yes look
he probably wasn't well held lawrence
was older than him i we don't even have
any direction we're gonna talk about
here but this is this is actually
something that I'd talk about alright
five brookie quarterbacks right you
starting all five starting three of the
five what are you gonna do hmm
well I'm not starting all five I'm
definitely not gonna start Lamar Jackson
yeah are you gonna take back your bet
with that guy like are you just gonna
pay up now that Lamar is not gonna take
five snaps in the first week that's
Rosner yeah so do you are you I am very
worried about that I what with I know
he's gonna get a couple snaps at
quarterback they're gonna put him in
there for nothing else just to hand the
ball off and and keep the defensive end
from coming to or you know chasing the
runner right or something like that I
know I think he'll be on the field for
five plays but the five plays at
quarterback man if he'd let me out of
bed for with 50% right now I'd give him
half bet so I don't feel too good about
it because I watched the tape of the
game I did see somebody show it on TV
and it was just not good I mean Evers he
dropped back and on Monday
Gaming their people wide open I mean
wide open and he just won't look and
throw to him yet he will he did it
Louisville but it's just gonna still
taking time yeah and and you know the
guy who made the point I don't know who
I was watching but they made a good
point you know too many the runs I know
it's early Yeah right
but come on baby yeah it's not all too
much contact a pile right man
he got drilled yeah I think I think
booger and Jason wouldn't kind of set it
during the game and you know it but
somebody did a really breakdown and I'd
like I told you I watched it because I
wanted to watch Andrew Luck I said well
let me watch the Baltimore on the other
side too so watch both and and you know
he could have he could have thrown some
passes and driven the ball down the
field throwing the football yeah and
yeah that's the one thing we haven't
seen him do yet he has not driven the
ball with any authority and any throw
yeah that's the thing I've been
complaining about on the podcast Phil
Laak has not done it either and I don't
know you know I'm waiting to see maybe
this to interview Andrew Luck is gonna
be all year but you know the good thing
is Frank Reich will work around that
that's for sure yep yeah what do you
guys think about Andrew Luck yeah I know
what Dad saying we haven't seen the you
know he never had like a hundred mile
per hour fastball right he was like a 95
mile-per-hour fastball guy but he's a
great down the field thrower I think I
would agree that right he's one of the
best deep ball throws we haven't seen
him throw a deep ball yet like I've seen
him do it
haven't seen him really throw like a
20-yard comeback or anything like that
where he sent a step on a little bit
it's my thing has been the exact same
motion every row and also I think right
now it's only two little exhibition
games I thought the father C is throwing
the football in the air is 33 yards
right so the last gear know what that
was a fade or why can't I don't know the
play but some I heard somebody say no 33
yards is the farthest as he's thrown
about in a game I didn't watch that film
yet dad but I would also say to it like
it just seemed on TV like nobody was
open and I know T why Hilton didn't play
so did when when you watched luck did
you think people were actually open
downfield because I do write you know
listen he's he's always been I think a
very good decision maker his
yet my pet peeve with him you know in
him really when he was rolling was hey
check one down every now and then right
you know cuz he would fire down the
field and he kind of had that that
problem of just oh I'll just make a play
you know I'll just hold on and I'll
break the pocket run and do that kind of
stuff and it you know II got beat up
over it so yeah dad
another thing I think just because we're
on this game and that way you made this
point last week when you and I were
talking on the phone and I actually I
really liked it we were talking about
Lamar Jackson and dad made the point
like you have said it he doesn't look
quite as fast yet right I thought I
actually looked faster the other night
than he did in the first two preseason
games even like Colts turf yes so he did
he looked faster but dad made some good
points about we were comparing him to
Michael Vick yeah but the points you
made I'm gonna lead you in the direction
about well yeah okay yeah yeah he is
bursting is is what he says you don't
run as much in the pros as you do in
college like the quarterback in college
you run after practice and do those
things and the quarterback that might be
the only time you get to run really
because you're playing quarterback in
practice so dad was out his point is you
know you can become a hair slower in the
NFL if you don't know well become slow
right well not be as fast next year as
he is this year he will slow down unless
he works on it but yes okay so that
that's I thought was a great picture
your guys are saying there's no running
drills for a quarterback in practice no
and then FL they don't run enough
anyways I don't but just think in
college Adam all you do is practice lift
weights run run all summer long and it
and he's never gonna be like that ever
again the rest of his life unless he
goes to the Patriots no don't run but
they don't he's not you just can't do it
because there's too much involved with
all the mental aspects of the game and
you just knock and look college he could
do it on the fly he can't do that as
much in the pros right and everybody
sleep well go ahead finish up else about
Michael yeah so then the other point was
I said yeah I mean he might I was like
not as fast as michael vick but dim he's
close he can really you know and dad
said you know what he goes the league's
a lot faster now than when michael vick
played and we said that i was like damn
you're right dad I mean yeah really it's
I then when Michael Vick came in the
league it was a league of just about
being big right Levon Kirkland was still
playing Kirkland would be a defensive
tackle now yes and he would be probably
at all-pro Deon Jones would be a safety
back then yeah right right right so so
it was League it was just big people and
then Michael Vick arguably might have
been the fastest guy in the NFL except
maybe Deion Sanders or you know a few
people so that's not the case anymore
the NFL is I'm watching these games and
all these preseason games go who is it
I'm looking up I going Tammy is a free
agent yeah that's cool - go - holy
Christ he looks like an all-american
all-pro right there and I just there's a
lot of guys the many good players and
and I think the depth at quarterback and
the NFL is tremendous it really is
revelation 2020 something good
quarterbacks listen the league I'm not
going to get into this but also and you
know maybe Lamar look faster - I thought
you were saying it just like it off my
mind right it's because he's starting to
get into that get it into better shape
right right you know get into real
football shape and now he helped pick up
speed as we go along maybe to me he
still looks like he's ten pounds heavier
now than he was available I agree it
does look a little thicker and I just
just don't don't do it right you know
that you know guys do - at the end of
their career cuz they're trying to look
good physically they go he looks great
you know but but they it's fake wait
yeah it's always what really does is
hurt him right and so we talked about
the backups oh yeah yeah backups in the
NFL not gonna get deep into it but a lot
of teams have what I call a really good
backup that he's good enough to come in
the game and you know here's my one of
my pet piece well you know he's the
backup
because you know he can get us in and
out of the huddle and he really knows
the system and I go I don't give a crap
can he make a play he can't throw it and
he can't run but oh but he really is
just got command to the offense oh man
go in the room and just take the door
like the Three Stooges
put your head in it and open the door
just keep slamming yourself in the head
because that is stupid and some of these
teams yeah they're taking a tremendous
risk they lose their starting
quarterback their year is over right I
mean Matt Cassell still the league it's
insane so Phil you would have good
perspective on this and this is my last
one I'm going down to Rutgers later to
get the kids of this racial speech
really yeah I really am I'm gonna talk
to them at the practice so I'm talking
to my squad yeah josh is a big Rutgers
fan oh really yeah tell me some stuff
well I'm uh I'm out checking check them
out watch practices you know I'm not
gonna be there for the whole practice
practice with us you want to like try
out something yeah what are you gonna
say your motivational sponse I'm gonna
tell them some truths about life man
mm-hmm
you know you can't pull me so all right
so my quest for this way I won't be long
as mr. mayor told me as I got up the
emcee at dinner one time for him Boys
and Girls Club and they're introducing
me and he puts his hand on my shoulder
and he goes Phil just remember I want
you to know I've been to church every
day of my life since I can remember
three years old
he goes I never once left church ever
and said wow I wish the sermon was a
little longer and I go I got you mr.
mayor I'll keep this thing moving at an
unbelievable pace here we go that's the
same thing with these kids yeah well
tell them a couple little things you
know yeah you know what they don't want
to hear it
they've already heard everything so I
think I got one or two things they
probably haven't heard so I'll go with
that Chris who was the youngest player
in the NFL the youngest player in the
NFL yeah I want to say Sam darn 'old
youngest player in the NFL is Tremaine
Edmund oh that's right cuz he was by the
team when he got born May
second 1998 yes Adam Vinatieri has been
playing in the NFL since 1996 Adam
Vinatieri has been playing in the NFL
longer than Tremayne Edmonds has been
alive
how crazy isn't it yeah it is crazy I
saw I was looking at it I said god this
guy's 20 years old
holy Christ that's amazing yeah to be 20
in the NFL but how about Vinatieri what
a 57-yard or the other night oh yeah
yeah I mean they got it down you know
they're these kickers punters and
kickers are like the modern-day golfer
they got the technique down so perfect I
mean it you are we all surprised at any
time in a game we see a miss a field
goal yeah now they kick a 55 yard or I
just kill what he'll make it and I feel
like for you I mean a missed field goal
got your ring yes right you're right I
miss field goal yeah kicking back then
was not near as good as it is now
no it was not my gosh yeah the numbers
of these kickers right that was a
47-yard field goal then a 47-yard field
goals are like slam dunks now in the NFL
back then it was literally like miss
50/50 it's gone
well let's punish let's don't even try
it you know that now I I'm even shocked
regular-season games you know think all
they gotta put in here 53 yards I'll
kick it you know they make it and I just
came out but it never made that decision
if I was a head coach but hey it's a
game that we're learning that you got to
take chances and it's the old thing you
got to dare to be great you can't be
afraid and sometimes you got to take
chances practicing is Rutgers hey
alright so sorry I didn't get to finish
my quarterback thing right just real
quick all right in in Josh Allen are you
starting them week one if they were not
playing the Baltimore Ravens in
Baltimore I would start him absolutely
100%
but that scares you but man yeah that
you know who knows what they're gonna
have cooked up week one no doubt about
it at these games in that crowd I think
Baltimore's a good football team there
you know listened there they there it's
Harbaugh watching him coach on TV was
hilarious
yeah other night yeah you're going for
it I mean he is just mad as hell he's
too in coaches on this and but you know
what they like nothing better than a
15-round knock-down drag-out that's what
they want to do and that that's the only
way that that's the only hesitation I
have about starting ok that game ok one
their new offensive coach they're not a
great team
yeah right him are they well coached yes
they're welcome I know there's no he
doesn't have a lot of help around him to
make big plays or anything
ok all right next guy Rosen or Bradford
what would you do
I'm going Bradford yeah you are yeah
absolutely that's the only that's the
right thing to do you know Sam Bradford
you know what Adam you know what I know
it he's he's dead I dick I mean he
doesn't miss ya and so oh and it kind of
bugs me a little bit oh he's gonna get
hurt sometime we all know that ok all
right well maybe he won't
what about Baker Mayfield if he goes out
and lights the world on fire and
preseason game number three they're not
gonna let him he's not gonna you know I
got no restaurant of one so he's not
going to start that's that's we know
that point for three that's over three
and then so we already know Lamar's damn
darlin and I know it's named Arnold you
think TJ's gonna start right look Josh
Allen no I'm gonna say I'm gonna say
it's I'm gonna say it's 60 maybe 70 30
that he does start I think he does right
and I know that so dad this is the thing
with Buffalo - yeah why then it's
Chargers at home so it's at the Ravens
Chargers at home then it's at the
Vikings and at the Packers so that's how
Josh Allen would have to start his
career and if you waited through the buy
which is a week 11 by damn it's the
worst team to play in all of sports it's
the Jacksonville Jaguars so that's where
it's just the only good thing is it'll
be the end of November in Buffalo and I
don't know if Jacksonville wants to be
in man I'm just talking about him you
know it's really interesting some dummy
wrote you know his completion
senate's for the preseason is just what
it was in college and he's another one
take your head put in a door and slam it
on yourself
ya know watching him he's been I think
better than I thought he would look on
an NFL field field he definitely looks
like he's lost 10 pounds
he's very it looks fast as can be he can
beat you around the edge and it's good
work in the pocket it looks awesome it
looks awesome
same with Baker Mayfield is footwork in
the pocket has been outstanding for a
young guy usually don't see it and same
as him darling
Sam d'Arnaud has been very good the only
thing about that and I know the Jets are
hampered with their offensive lines beat
up I want to see Sam Darnell throw the
ball down the field yeah I know that's
we send the same thing we agree but I
haven't seen is he thrown one pass you
know you got it hey it's a league a big
place and I know they're doing it in
practice I know that so and they're
being very careful and smart so I'm not
gonna even second-guess them because the
Redskins hey you know there's no real
team wallflowers up there and that
defensive front yeah oh my god what
doron pain oh man how good did he look
I'm so good I know oh my gosh as I said
to Christopher he was probably a running
back in peewee football then he was just
a big running back because he got
probably as a freshman in high school
and they just said damn boy you're too
big we gotta put your hand underground
because he looks like a running back
still with his body it's just huge
yes you know it's unbelievable yeah they
could they the Redskins
I like them as a football team they just
they're one of those teams like the
charges they get the injury bug yeah
look I like Greg minovsky as a defensive
coordinator I hear I think he's done a
good job he's ever really had a good
defense right you know when he was at
the Colts think maybe come on even up
there they play tough in there exactly
right nobody can even name guys on that
deal and you know he's clever you know
and you know look hey he can stir it up
I mean I don't know you know the Jets
were down and they you know just because
some people were telling me he was
absolutely hilarious yes he's one of
those guys as a coach he can get on you
but it doesn't hurt your feelings he's
going to
kind of got that magic accordance he is
an ex-player - yeah all right dad you
the man all right let me let me write
down what I'm most saying now boys go to
school to get straight A's that's all
you're gonna do it's all about education
so are you don't worry about to play in
it's education history coach is going
shut up yeah you don't believe that
either all right he was talking smack
about Ali [ __ ] Sheikh what was that was
that what he was saying that kickers
can't make things bad right well it
definitely it is it is definitely
something we talk about a lot now it's
just wow 50 yards or so
so guaranteed I know it's your mother
another mother yeah man he can talk you
can really talk you can't lead them down
those limehawk Tom yes what are you
gonna save the Brooker speech he's gonna
tell you the whole damn speech if you
ask him that yeah I don't wanna shut up
both you a dress rehearsal would have
been great all right we are now gonna go
into sims's news and notes he has sent
me pictures of his game film watch from
the other week two preseason games here
at Sims left go I don't lead you on and
not deliver I'm gonna make sure you get
what you need we're gonna start off with
Bengals Cowboys okay it's I wrote down I
text you this and I said how does Jaylon
Smith look yeah wrote down in your notes
she wrote Jamis Jaylon Smith is not
totally what he wasn't but he did can't
even read Jaylon Smith is not totally
what he was but a lot better than last
year yes so where does this put him in
the grand scheme I mean he at least last
year I felt like he was playing and they
only had him out there because they had
given a second draft second-round pick
on a guy like a liability he was he was
a liability I felt like they tried to
hide him this year he shows up I mean
you can see like explosion and
athleticism and he can make a difference
on plays from sideline to sideline and
all those things where last year I was
just like oh my gosh it's a waste of
time he can't he couldn't even run right
and I still don't still think he's got a
little hitch in his giddyup but it's
barely noticeable if you have
really watched him so yeah I have hope
for him that he's gonna continue to get
better and maybe you're close to that
guy we saw who was a definite top five
pick I wrote down in my notes man the
Cowboys D lion has some impressive
freakin athlete does you went on to say
also the Cowboys mixed up coverage a lot
more on D and a was en Byron Jones
really look the part yes you said the
Cowboys have a team concept big physical
sound right and be good at that exactly
right so in a weird way you're you're
pretty confident in this cowboy style I
do I do feel I feel confident I think
about the Cowboys altogether with just
the way they look yeah the defense I
think is more talented than maybe I and
all of us have given it credit for they
have tremendous depth and size on the D
line well they're like 10 deep they
really are you know and then yes the
secondary guys like judo Bo Lussier
Byron Jones a corner which is what he
did in college you know the Jordan Lewis
Anthony Brown there's four guys there
where I go Byron Jones is playing corner
who's back there with Jeff Heath so is
Xavier woods I just got hurt from a get
hurt no Xavier woods he's got some
ability I mean he's kind of a I'm not
saying he's Earl Thomas he's Earl Thomas
and stature that smaller type guy that's
really explosive now he's also a little
out of control him was hurt Byron Jones
in the game with friendly fire and then
he hurt himself by diving on the
incompletion to where that was a bad
throw by Andy Dalton to AJ Green and AJ
Green's need looked I could hit him in
the hamstring or whatever so he's out
but either way yes I like what I see out
of the Cowboys d-line and then their
offensive line we know that we just got
a knock it hurt we haven't yet or banged
right yeah we haven't seen Zeke yet I
think Zach's gonna be totally fine and
the receivers are good but not great but
they're not trying to go find one-on-one
matchups and do that they're gonna have
their little system a bludgeon you in
the run game bootlegs screens and then
some semi basic downfield concepts
throwing the football
Bengals side um I mean and II don't just
don't got it no I just you know like I
think you came to the realization last
year
yeah where you said I'm officially
giving up he's he's not a top 15
quarterback and now with all the better
quarterbacks in the league he's just not
there no it's just lesser in the league
no doubt about it it's getting worse
yeah it is it's where I look at teams
like them and you know again the Jaguars
where I just go damn they're they're
really below average at a very important
position at this day and age in the NFL
like he should not be missing AJ Green
by that much twice plays right that are
designed to get AJ curry in the ball yes
like like a nice little stack where AJ
Green get to the outside as he runs the
fade route guys have been together now
for seven years right right that's just
no longer well we're working out the
kinks right it's not a thing no you got
to make plays and he doesn't if you're
not gonna make plays with throwing then
you better be athletic and be able to
escape either right so that's where it's
defensively though yeah we're still wild
by the secondary you wrote William
Jackson Dre Kirkpatrick are phenomenal
yes the Bengal secondary is legit right
it is legit you know and then you bring
in dark has Denard as their Nickelback
and you know at safety I really like
this Bates kid they got in the second
round at a Wake Forest that was a big
fan of him so I do look at them and
along with Shawne Williams and go damn
here I don't care what your weapons you
got all offensively against the bangles
you're gonna have your work cut out for
you
getting open but yeah you know I just
the Bengals have been a hair less
impressive than I was expecting so far
this preseason oh good I know the
offense my big issue of that what is the
offense what is it what what are they
they to me when I watch the Bengals
often say go
what exactly are you trying to get
accomplished I don't really understand
what you do what's your theme of your
offense it's just like all we do a
little of this and we do a little of
that and we just throw it out there and
we're not really great at anything and
we're not even really good at everything
but we have everything in our playbook
well great that's gonna do jack [ __ ] for
you throughout a 16-game season yeah all
right let's move on to Broncos bears so
I agree with everything you're saying
it's the problem with the Bengals yeah
it's like looking at Josh cuz he's
acting like he's interested but he's
really like doing another job where he's
like worried about yeah they can look at
sorry I'm just gonna ask when you say
theme of an offense what is it what is
it
theme of an offense a theme of offense
is like what are like two or three plays
that you see that are like scheme why is
that the exact same play every time but
a similar scheme like the Cowboys I know
what they are they're pulling guard
downhill run ski on him that wants to
use a little play-action pass office and
like like I said some basic just drop
back passes that's what they are like
there's no mo to the to their offense
there's nothing I can just go oh okay
you know the Patriots what do they do
there's they have a million different
short drop back passing games where they
can be surgical and they make you defend
that and then all of a sudden you go
whoa there's Gronkowski twenty yards
down the field wide open why well
because you've been worried about
stopping all these seven and eight yard
option routes that's why that's why when
we talk about the Jaguars being
unstoppable right they you know exactly
what our with Leonard fournette and
they've based a screen game and some
shots down the scene exactly a company
exactly Broncos Bears want to start off
the Bears offense it's a offense that a
lot of people are drafting members for
their fantasy teams right you wrote
Allen Robinson isn't totally healthy yet
which i think is a little bit scary you
said you really like the way try Biscay
looks he stripes it every time yes
shrimp stripes it every time always in a
good position to throw the football has
good anticipation yeah I mean sure
brewski is a pure thrower of the ball he
really is it's not the strongest arm in
the NFL but it's a good strong arm and
he's a good athlete oh you you obviously
said Trey Burton looks good I wrote in
my notes man Trey burns could have a
monster year I love that he's wearing a
tee he looks like a wide receiver out
there right I thought Anthony Miller had
a few really beautiful catches three
weeks in a row Anthony Miller pops for
them he is going to be a big part of
their offense as a rookie and then you
wrote Kevin white opening up looking
pretty damn good looking pretty damn
good really yeah I mean I got hope for
Kevin white from what I saw last week I
said oh yeah it's good that he's in an
offense now where he's like the fifth
option yeah I know and there was a there
was a play in the game I can't remember
who we ended up throwing to true Biscay
dropped back and it was go routes on
both sides and he threw the ball on the
left side I want to say he threw it to
Allen Robinson and Kevin white had blown
by the guy on the other side but little
things like that the routes caught up
what he caught two or three passes I
believe and just look good that
he's gonna contribute to this team the
big takeaway though for the Bears often
she wrote it's very interesting and they
have a lot of different ways to [ __ ]
with you they do they have a lot of
different ways and guys and today of the
line to given us yes I like the role
line I really do I mean I think it's
it's one of the better lines in the
sport and they they blood jordan Howard
I mean he Moran sue them holes that were
gigantic I mean they bludgeon the
Broncos no he's not Iowa kid James
Daniel's getting in he's not in yet the
the her bonus cross is not at center
right yeah that's what's crazy is they
have these two guys that I'm like that's
what they're all why it's really gonna
take a it could there's no doubt but
these guys that they got in there
they're they're good players too I mean
white hair is a good player yeah having
long at one guard Leno and then who's
their right tackle is that Bobby Massey
and I can time I have so many goodness
in my head yes but yes I do like the
Maris offense could be special I'd yes I
do
the Broncos defense facing that bears
offense I'm gonna I'm gonna single out
here Bradley Chubb yeah what was your
big takeaway on Briley Joe Bradley Chubb
physically belongs there's no question
about that
he's biggie strong the the explosive
factor I don't see that there yet like I
just don't see a guy that has impressed
me with you know first step explosion
getting around the edge flying down the
line of scrimmage and a run that goes to
the opposite side little things like
that I haven't seen the unleashing of
yet and again I think this is why he was
not in the class of Khalil Mack and
miles Garrett and Jadeveon Clowney
coming out even though I know everyone
thought he was maybe the number two pick
in the draft that's this is why he was
not because he wasn't a guy when I saw
him on the field in Notre Dame where I
was just like whoa whoa look at that
first step that's pretty humble around
the edge he's a really good football
player and maybe he's thinking a lot
right now too and he can unleash it
which is a very real thing in the NFL so
I are you under well yeah a little
underwhelmed to this point yes I would
have expected a little bit more of a WOW
factor
I mean it's great in a game in which he
gets a safety I know but it was a bad
complete drama they dropped and I
thought him leaping though is impressive
yeah sure Brisky dropped the snap to so
on the other side the Broncos as a whole
you're not sure about this
yeah they have a lot of solid and good
just nothing great yeah it's pretty
crazy how this defense has fallen off
yeah I two years yes it is it's I
definitely have my questions about the
Broncos I mean you no offense I mean I
know they they were able to get around
and get a few good drives we skeet him
in there right but even when it was
clicking it didn't look dynamic you know
it just looks like it was operated yes
Demaryius Thomas was not out there so no
I will say that but yeah I don't look at
the run game and go wow I don't look at
their past game and go wow I just don't
know again almost like we were saying
with some of the other teams I don't
know what to hang their hat on what do
you when you play them what are you
gonna have to go oh we have to stop this
or we're screwed
Chad Kelly so Chad Kelly was phenomena
and the defense can still be really good
I'm not saying it's not gonna be good
but I don't know if it's gonna be able
to dominate the way maybe I thought it
could dominate Chad Kelly Chad Kelly I
mean he's been I think one of the most
impressive young cubies so far this
preseason
yeah it's factoring in the rookies and
everybody yeah it's um athletically arm
talent all that is top notch and he was
very impressive in that game I mean very
well you see is the future man I mean
the Paxton Lynch thing is over and I
think that Chad Kelly you know whether
they trust him to be the backup quite
yet I don't know but there's no problem
if I'm Chad Kelly I'd be like oh if I'm
the third string so what who cares for
him it's just about staying really he is
that diamond in the rough mold where he
could be a starter at some point because
he's got that kind of talent and
physical ability to wear okay yeah other
than just reps what needs to be improved
I'm to be that start he has a little bit
he's got a little bit of a long gait in
motion at times he could tighten up and
there's throws where it is tight and you
go oh if he could do that instead of
like having this long baseball lined up
a time said he gets away with against
second and third teamers where I go tell
them Smith they're miles jacker they're
you're not gonna get away with that so
just little things like that maybe
processing a little bit too you know if
you you don't have to process is quick
verse the second and third teamer stew
because the players aren't as good and
now because he has a strong arm he can
get away with it because he can go i I
fit it in there because I put everything
I got to do it where if it was the
starters you go on that's gonna be
tipped in the air and intercept
or whatever it is uh his throat a
Cortland Sutton was beautif beautiful he
is you if he has some Wow throws these
are I love when you find the little guys
little gems to keep our eyes on - from
this game
you said Roy Robertson Harrison yeah
huge and disrupted yes this is a barest
offensive lineman the Bears the Bears
are they're one of my man crushes I
think in football they say they got a
collection some bad mofo comeback
exactly right some bad mofos Andrew a
Robertson Harris I mean he's six seven
he's 294
I mean he's hit the arm farm it looks
like many of the times I mean I respect
that he was a beast in the football game
I mean with him and I know I'm Hakeem
Hicks isn't even playing and you got
Jonathan Bullard and our man Eddie
Goldman right you just keep going
through it and you go damn they got a
lot of ass kickers good luck moving that
group Leonard Floyd broke his hand I
know and hopefully he'll be back just
club people yeah the other name you
wrote was is this a Denver running back
Phillip Lindsey the number two number
two yes he just I look he first of all
he pops when you watch them they don't
have a guy like that right I think all
like Royce Freeman and all them are kind
of like Reese Freeman is there they're
kind of their little plotting they're
plotting right there between the tackle
runners that are not sexy and this is
the only guy that comes in to go oh he
can be electric in space he got in there
with the starters so that tells me right
away that they value him it might have
only been a few plays but he got in
there that's a big clue to always look
for like oh they put him in there that
means they trusted him to be with that
the big thing that I see a lot of people
saying online is if you get in with the
starters that's obviously a big key
right and if you're fighting for an old
line or a D line for a roster spot are
you on punt and kicks and if you're all
those you're typically gonna make the
team no doubt if you're not right you're
probably not gonna make exactly right
like those guys who are fighting yeah
you're right for the backup defense a
tackle or backup you know that are you
blocking field car you exactly right are
you on are you on punt coverage can you
rush the punter whatever it is yes that
that will break those tie breakers a lot
of people wanted your take on that I'm
wearing the Chucky shirt and you wrote
about Gruden's offense yes second week
in a row very basis no basis it's 12
of personnel and West right slot almost
every play right Raiders are playing
nobody
Gruden is saving it all for week one of
the regular season he's going he's going
he's going zero dark thirty with his
offense and not gonna show anybody what
did you like that I do like it and we
had years in Tampa where were you like
that and I always want to go I would
love to look back and I would I go I bet
you those are our good years in office
like the year 2006 when I lost my spleen
man he pissed me off so many times in
the preseason he called some of our best
plays with the third string quarterback
in there because he wanted to get
somebody off or something they want to
prove that his fifth round wide receiver
was good and I would sit there on the
side as a big are you I would little are
you putting that on sailfin kidding me
you're calling this play in the third
quarter of a preseason game like are you
kidding me giving away like a gem right
don't do that and yes I hopefully he's
doing that and I also think there's the
baby factor here where the offense this
is baby Derek cars is baby Jordy
Nelson's his baby he doesn't want to put
them out there until it looks really
good
that's the way he is but see you're
thinking this first week against the
Rams Gruden's gonna be saving just some
laziness major major mind ethic coaches
watch is what do you study if you're
facing Griggs that you're gonna study
old they're gonna study old films
that's wild that it's gonna be teams
going back in 2007 yes
coaches watched the end of preseason
games to see what he's doing with the
third stringers and four stringers yeah
they're gonna they're gonna watch it all
because they're just gonna be like damn
we gotta just just account for
everything we do we gotta just got to
look at everything no doubt and yes he I
would think he's gonna come out and just
do you have to do that against every
team or just John Gurdon no you didn't
do that against every team but it's
gonna be more I think in depth of good
man because everybody's gonna be trying
to look for any new angle that you think
he might be bringing yes now he is kind
of showing one little nugget if you want
to call him little Chris Warren seed um
so I love when you end up writing notes
about guys that the internet loves a lot
of people have been asking you to talk
about Texas running back
Warren who was a rookie was he undrafted
or was he directed undrafted on the
Raiders I just wanted him to be a tight
end so that was the issue there that's
how big he is yeah he's six for 250
this is LexA Brandon Jacobs this is
Brandon Jacobs but smoother okay so I'm
gonna read what sim said about Chris
Warren Raiders fans getting been Wow
it's better on film than TV he always
falls forward has great body control and
very smooth Gruden likes these types of
guys again he's Alstott ish will only be
better with the first team offense he's
working vs backups and that actually
hurts his style of running I think he is
as good or better than every running
back the Raiders have when it comes to
pure running game yeah so this is not
just some preseason dude that's playing
because Gruden's sitting all the
starters know this is a this is an NFL
starting running back if you want that
LeGarrette Blount type of guy and I say
that because well first of all like I
said the body control visions good I
mean a guy gets hit at the line of
scrimmage and you go Dan they're gonna
get no yards and you go beau its second
and seven holy [ __ ] he dragged that guy
for six more feet and they hit him
square in the and the hip or whatever it
was he is not gonna go like 60 70 yards
we can go 30 and 40 a lot and starting
offensive line is going to help a lot of
the times there's nowhere for him to run
he can't get going
when he has real awesome alley in there
and Rodney Hudson and he gets lanes to
continue to gather his speed and
momentum and the beauty of these guys is
it gets to the third quarter and the
talents miss of the world and the
linebackers just got what I got a I got
a square him up again yeah and he starts
to pile and Rashard for 280 they got
this guy they got him and then they
start to go damn I squared him up so
many times my neck already hurts
let me start throwing my shoulder in and
then you missed tackles and that's what
happens but I think he has tremendous
value to their team I will be shocked if
he's not used throughout and you think
that in your history with Cruden this is
like a key cog of his office I do I
think backbreakers yes Mike I think if
he gets a lead in the fourth quarter
these are the kind of he wants this guy
to run the ball he I think he's gonna
maybe even want him more than Marshawn
when it gets to this more Sean's gonna
be the starter and he's gonna get all
the early carries but I think he's gonna
go man we're up by 8/3 late third
quarter fourth quarter and I want to
start pounding the rock he's gonna go
I'm gonna pound the rock with this guy
because he's gonna be fresh Marshawn
Abee a little tired bad that point and
it's just another fresh body that could
bludgeon people and yeah that's when it
was Alstott time in Tampa I'm trying to
remember when he was with the Raiders he
had another fullback Richie John written
Richie who's four had always bled and
that but that was the guy that he used
as the all-star role as a back break on
Gruden he remember the Raiders came in
to Philadelphia one time and he just
milked the end of the clock with John
Ritchie right and John Rich and did a
plan for the Eagles so but but I
remember it was he loved to demoralize
teams loves it so this is his John
Ritchie Mike Alston I think so I do
that's pretty cool it is cool and then
you also just kind of threw this in
there you said by the way EJ Manuel is
better than Connor Cook I mean yeah I
don't you know the kind of cook thing I
don't see it to me he just looks at a
place and there's nothing special about
him physically
EJ had one play where he did fumble the
ball and batted it around either way but
EJ at least his fearless in the pocket
and he'll let the ball go I don't know
if I could say that much for Connor cook
I'm reaching a point Josh longer to my
own horn to do it that way when I write
down my notes and then I see Sims as
notes I'm like I'm not an idiot
well you know why because you I mean
you've been learning for four days I'm
learning what to see 49ers team in tutus
I wrote this down I wrote
deshaun Watson looks freaking surgical
and then I put in parentheses Ellington
right so both of these things you wrote
but this is the big one Sims is what
matters on that show you wrote I just
can't get over how awesome deshaun
Watson looks wow he is so good yeah like
Jimmy G he's always in good position
he just has a better fastball yeah so I
was worried that I'm just watching to
show him once I'm going its preseason
those guys are open but it just looks
lazy your look right your trust on the
look man he's right down the seam
perfect liable and it does it so quick
and easy right just drive the gear are
you expecting for the Shawn Watson ah
man yeah that we have talked about his
sealing for his career right but this
year yeah I mean this year you know I I
guess I'd still like to see him run
around I haven't seen that part of it
yet but man his throwing has come so far
in one year and it's really
decision-making and just seeing it and
letting it go and like we talked about
last year with you know we didn't see
the fastball a lot coming out of college
and we saw it more and more as the year
went on last year and this year it just
came out it's it's every throw it's
every throw it doesn't matter anymore
he's throwing the heater are we talking
like a possible MVP type campaign I
think if they if they can be a good
all-around football team which I do
think the Texans are a team again to
like watch out for I mean that's a tough
division but damn let's not forget it
was the number one defense in football
just two years ago and now they got the
Shawn Watson so yeah they can do some
dangerous things yeah he is he has a
chance to be the best quarterback in
this league when Aaron Rodgers game
falls off this is the guy
Carson Wentz who else am I missing you
know are you gonna say Jimmy G yeah
Russell Wilson yeah you know no I'm not
gonna put Jimmy G in there categoría
because I don't think his pure
bottom-line physical ability is Josh but
Josh Allen they can be the guys that you
could go their necks like this is the
star of the league they can take over it
doesn't matter what their offense is or
who they got they can make it happen
other these are some fantasy news and
notes you wrote Lamar Miller looks like
he lost some weights and as a step
faster does which is a lot of fantasy
community realized that Lamar Miller is
gonna but when deshaun Watson was in
exactly it made him such a better runner
and he's the style of runner quick cut
get up the field act like that he's
perfect to be paired what to Shawn why
yes he is he looks really explosive I
think
more is better than people have given
him credit for either I went through a
period - in Miami where I was a little
bit yeah I was it cuz I don't know but I
think the deshaun Watson points the
point that you made it's you know he's
he had to go to the Texans with Tom
savage at first and nobody was scared of
the pass game and their offensive line
was beat up so let's not forget that so
there was issues but yeah DeShawn's a
difference maker he makes their defense
a defense that plays them their approach
has to be totally different
it was the Bruce Ellington revenge game
the Niners but Ellington you wrote looks
to be their slot guy and he looks good
he does look good so you see a DeAndre
Hopkins will fuller Bruce helling I
think so yes with a little bit of our
old quarterback from Ohio State thrown
in rather than me Jackson in a little
bit but yes I think those are the three
guys you're gonna see Ellington looks
like he's going to be the Wes Welker of
this all it does seem to be that way
which is perfect member former running
back wide receiver basketball player
he's the super athletic sits down can go
either way
49ers though you weren't that high on
them after this game you you thought
Jimmy G looks so comfortable look good I
don't work I'm not questioning the often
no I know what you wrote down this is
what Sims wrote you wrote 49ers
offensive line looks so much better this
year
McGlinchey and Richburg just changed the
look completely yes so there's a pocket
now yeah and McGlinchey look great yes
great pocket their brunt and they're
gonna be able to do more in the run game
blocking and scheming because they're
just add more athletic guys and Kyle
couldn't ask some of those guys to do it
laughs this is why I'm going to draft a
lot of Niners on fantasy oh yeah you
wrote how can this Niners defense be
good there's no way the Niners are gonna
have to score 35 points a game Rueben
Foster is the only baller on that side
of the analysts and what I mean baller
listen there's good players but I want
egg baller is a guy that can go above
and beyond right you don't think to
Forrest Buckner no I think they're good
players but Reubens the only guy that
can go or Specter on our curve stood
together as one they like they have a
lot of solid but I just don't know if
there's those different makers and when
you say like above and beyond it goes up
to our whole [ __ ] the playoffs at or
whatever like hey you're responsible for
the a gap but there's no like law that
says you can't make the tackle if the
ball goes to the D gap and that's where
Rubin
can do that kind of stuff on a on a
great defense yeah in a given year
how many ballers are there that can go
above and beyond yeah like like a like
okay Jacksonville's out of the norm
they have like seven yeah I mean they
have I was thinking I need you to doom
Hadley do meds yeah five or six I think
your elite defense is the Bronco run
goes hit like five I believe Chris
Harris Ron melon 49ers have one right
exactly and he's only a second-year he's
a second-year player who's gonna be
suspended right for the first game or
two of the year so yeah I mean the
Vikings let's take them again four or
five right I mean so guys that okay
maybe three or four didn't ball out in
this game but we had two others who
found a favorable matchup and kicked ass
right yeah false are suspended for the
first two but yeah I think you like
Jimmy Ward you think a kilo Wetherspoon
looks really good right and they could
be good but they're just missing the
difference makers they're trying to hang
in on every Syria exactly right I felt
the Broncos felt the same way to me a
little bit I feel like they're hanging
in like they get a third down stop after
letting up three first downs like yes
and like they're relieved they're not
imposing their will
I would agree Bucs Titans I came away
from watching the Titans so excited yeah
with this offense the slants the screens
Dion Lewis being out there the the
routes they're doing for Mariota you
echoed that and you wrote down the
Titans offense would be so much easier
for Mariota you do throw this in you
said but his throwing is still not up to
par to be great so he's still missing
something he is yes what is he missing
it's it's just like we talked about with
it you know without getting technical I
mean he just doesn't have that natural
flow that like we just talking about but
deshaun Watson who can take you know
take a five step drop he hits that back
foot and it all just comes together as
one flowing motion and it's a great
throw Mariota just to paint a picture he
takes a five-set drop and he sits there
real stiff and upright and then his
upper body doesn't move and it's just
his arm alone which I wish I could
demonstrate for people but yeah like
just if he's throwing to Josh he's just
here and never he never gets this like
you see how do you fix that
he doesn't whip his body he hasn't great
Torrey eight opposites or torque right
how do you tell someone to have
yeah well you can you can do it it's
just he's got to be taught it and maybe
shown it from other players and honestly
there's not a lot of quarterback you
know trees that can teach it or under
ball Phil Simms
but yeah right call Phil Simms is right
but yes that is an issue to me and
that's why there's a few balls in the
game that are errant because yes his arm
has to act like an independent
contractor and you know a golf swing a
tennis swing whatever it may be
everything's gotta if you want to be
consistently good at it you have to have
a technique that you can rely on one
thing though that is just gonna let
Chris off for saying his arm has to act
like an independent contractor yes what
does that mean it means like this body's
not helping his arm it's just all the
arm is doing everything everything right
like get like he's saying the torque
create the opposites get the shoulder
turn yet when we have a little catches
together I teach you guys like those
things he doesn't do that he kind of
just gets it frozen right at the target
and then he just goes I'm gonna just
throw from here and make it happen and
okay yeah he's a great athlete he does
it happen a lot thanks for quantifying
that yeah good I know I did those are
hard to quantify I will say this though
another fantasy nugget Tijuana Taylor
yeah so I know I want to give credit to
I think it's like Evan Norris at rota
worlds but on tail on Taylor now for
like three years but man was he fast in
that case yeah see what excited me about
the Titans is I felt like that Titans
are the number one team that always put
together 11 play drives and left with a
field goal opportunity and now with this
Lafleur offense I'm seeing guys like
taywan taylor catching the ball in space
with screen setup the FC idea louis
making people's miss and then i'm going
man they can pound you with Derek Henry
30 times now they have a flow Delaney
Walker's not playing now it just looks
like it's easy like you said it's gonna
be easier for Mariota and I'm a little
afraid of their defense they got good D
lineman their secondary he's got good
corners I Evans not playing at all or
practicing at all he's not gonna be up
to speed until like week six yeah he's
definitely not gonna be what they want
and I thought that team needed a new
middle linebacker and now they've just
lost their guys from last year and no
one's replacing them I know
so the Titans defense is scary
but you're a little bit more confident
yeah it's not a it's not in peace right
it is and it's via peas and Vrabel
together
yeah the d-line I mean it I think it's
big and physical it won't be pushed
around I think that's the good thing
about it yeah I mean I don't know if
there's that top tier pad pass rusher
and you're right the middle of the
defense the middle linebackers are yeah
there's question marks there by yard
artists are due to Dori Logan Torrey
Jackson there there there that's a good
three to have it back in they got Kenny
Vaccaro in there now who started as well
he looked good yeah but yeah there's
questions I get it but I do think it's
the first year where the offense is
gonna be able to be a little bit more of
a focal point of the team some of the
Bucs the Bucs d-line was definitely a
unit that could be pushed around last
year yeah they were small it was really
Gerald McCoy and a bunch of who the heck
knows exactly and they had these small
speed linebackers behind them they went
out this year and pretty quietly built a
D line that has left you and myself
impressed you wrote box T line has great
size no one should push them around just
not sure they have one great pass rusher
when you say these four names when you
go across Vinny curry from the Eagles
who was a very like solid pass rusher
run stopper yep
Gerald McCoy Jason pierre-paul right now
they're playing beau Allen yeah kee who
was who played more than Timmy Jernigan
in the Super Bowl for the Eagles right
but they still haven't played V to Vega
yep they got a pretty good deal I know
yes they do they just you don't think
Jay P P is gonna be 15 SEC's no I don't
I don't think that's the kind of player
your favorite guy Noah Spence Noah
Spence is a backup right Mitch unwinds
in there they got the Goulston kids so
yeah there's like eight or nine T there
is there it's a solid unit there
definitely is but yeah I don't know if
there's that absolute just ass kicker
difference-maker a part of the group I
think as via can be that guy but by the
via can be a real F the play up is there
a chance that because a lot of those
guys are holed up stand up guys like
McCoy can get in there and I don't know
that but what do well the Quan
Alexander's and Levante David's to do
that is gonna help them there's no doubt
the fact that there's gonna be more big
bodies up front it's gonna
allow them to ball hawk and run around
and be that kind of guy so that is uh
definitely listen that their big thing I
don't look at their personnel and go oh
there's someone demand anything Smith
that's what I'm looking at exactly right
that's that that's the big question
Sims is long-term issue with Mike Smith
is it's just basic it's the same thing
all the time
thirteen years running and if you just
if you watch film of a Mike Smith
defense you know where to attack it on
teams the good teams typically do
exactly right that's what scares me
MJ Stewart forced two fumbles little
stiff looking but still was active yeah
your big note though was you wrote
Jameis Winston really [ __ ] this team
damn yes he did gosh there's so much
better when he plays holy cow I mean
they're in trouble I mean it's just Ryan
Fitzpatrick is well you know he's
getting older it's never been that great
they have down the field weapons and I
can tell you he's not the down the field
thrower that anybody would want for that
his delivery is so long and I mean you
know he had to throw a post of DeSean
Jackson he had to take a crow hop like
he was a centerfielder for the Yankees
and then he under throws it so it's just
like there's plays there to be had I
don't know if he has the ability to take
advantage of it and Jameis Winston comes
in and it's just feel feel feel feel and
it's a shame because they could be
dangerous
he threw a deep ball to DeSean Jackson I
went wow he's even got the deep ball
down because that was his issue for a
long time I know he couldn't hit the
Sean line and now DeSean he's hitting
Mike Evans he's hitting Dino so your big
takeaway though it wasn't even like he's
good you just what an idiot yeah what an
idiot I mean he's screwing them he
really is
his actions and I'm not gonna defend him
at all no of course yeah
but um yeah they're an obviously a team
though what he gets back in week four
they can be dangerous real it adjusts
are they gonna be one in three I mean I
don't know why they're gonna be he's up
fourth what three games or four he stops
I find he's out for four I think the
Eagles just play him in week three
that's why I think yeah I thought it was
the first four it went down from six to
four right oh my oh three okay but you
look at him as a them as a team that can
they win without Jameis Winston right I
think it's gonna be very hard their game
is about being able to take advantage of
the fact that they have Mike Evans -
Sean Jackson
J Howard the good thing is they play
really they have three cake walks to
start the year Saints Eagles steal a
perfect that's how in three I most
likely yes
yeah because you need somebody that can
make some ball or ass plays at the
quarterback position against those three
yeah
I mean because that that.oh line I mean
it's it's better it's not great in Tampa
and you got to play those defensive
lines like you better have a quarterback
that's gonna be able to throw a ball
before the receiver comes out of the
break or can fit it into a tight window
or doesn't have a motion that takes four
seconds to get the ball out like yeah
that's where I'm yeah it's it stinks man
I feel for the glazier family and the
Bucs I kind of feel for Dirk cutter yeah
I do too because he's on the hot seat
right and now he stuck with Ryan
Fitzpatrick for the first three games
yep yeah but you're what it sounds like
to me is the Bucs are gonna be one of
those teams that they're out of it but
they're just ruining lives you're right
that's the one that that would be one of
the teams I would watch yeah like they
might ruin Carolina or Lana's playoff
games itself there are six and ten with
three wins over teams that just missed
the play right okay
last game to talk about before we send
off Steelers chart excuse me Seahawks
Chargers and I want to say this you you
didn't get a chance to write down notes
yeah but you did kind of tell me a few
things yeah and one thing I just got an
alert Chargers defensive back Michael
Davis gets way up and tips ball to
himself to intercept Drew Brees and
joint practice you told me right before
the show left go this 43 kid on the
Chargers Michael Davis he's really
interesting to me really interesting
like has baller potential what yeah I
mean he is a player he's long as hell I
saw him out there first and I was like
man 43 who the hell is this guy and saw
him take off and run and I said whoa
okay he's got like another gear I wasn't
expecting to see that I think they've
found their guy to me when I just
watched him on film man-to-man or that
cover three press bail that the Seattle
scheme askew up he's the perfect fit but
more or less I'm just more impressed
with his short area quickness for those
long guys that sometimes as an issue and
yeah they have found their guy I think
as far as
an opposite opposite corner from KC
Hayward is this the highlight right here
yeah I'm gonna show cheerio
yeah I mean Michael Davis he's from
Brigham Young he's six to 196
Derwin James still not out there but the
starter take me through the highlight
Wow yes oh so he's on top of the
receiver and that's our man um Sam
Michael Tom that's Michael Thomas he's
all over Michael Thomas drew brees tries
to throw one of his patent back shoulder
throws but this damn guy is so long he
got his hand back there and tipped it up
in the air and int I get very excited
with the Chargers years are some of the
notes I wrote down where the Chargers
are gonna be the most fun offense to
watch again I think I've heard our guy
Michael who's your friend o Lombardi
melon party talk about that you want
with your wide receiving core to build a
basketball team right that's that's what
he always signed yeah so Travis Benjamin
is your point card yeah Mike Williams is
your power forward right Keenan Allen's
your shooting guard down and then Trevor
Williams is like your your off guard
three yeah Tyrell William excuse me
Tyrone Williams right I love their wide
receiving credit too but I think the
thing about the Chargers that people are
forgetting they have a Pouncy I know
people are forgetting that they got the
Pouncy brother from Miami as their
center-right forest lamp their big
second-round pick at a Western Kentucky
is back they're healthy it's the
healthiest the offensive line has been
and I think when their best receiving
threats is Melvin Gordon yeah Melvin
Gordon is always ready to catch the ball
Melvin Gordon's always ready to turn it
upfield and if it's just Phillip Rivers
calling the offense out there with four
wide with Melvin in the back maybe they
don't need Hunter Henry like they have a
good enough weapons that they don't
really need the tight ends I know he
likes that I know but I know you're
right they can get away with it if
there's one team that doesn't need it
it's then Austin Eckler is a good
receiving option out of the backfield -
yeah I just the Chargers I'm worried
that I'm too excited
hi they are the super hot team they've
been that way from the end of last year
and then deservedly so but I'm worried
that that I'm gonna get all excited
about the Chargers and they're just
gonna let us down I'm putting our money
on two guys
to say they won't let us down Anthony
Lin just first of all I'm are you
confident because he's just he you know
he's not gonna let them read their
headlines and tell them how great that
he is a no-nonsense really impressed I
love Anthony Lin I really do I think he
has got big-time potentials a head coach
in the NFL and then Gus Bradley on the
defense aside you know I know it didn't
work well in Jacksonville boat damn he's
some hell of a defensive coordinator I
just think they have two guys they're
gonna stay on both sides of the ball's
ass all the time I can just tell you
this right now I'm picking that after
what I've seen I know it's only two
preseason games the Chargers are winning
the West I'm taking the Chargers a
little bit tear I'm just taking him I'm
taking them right don't even realize
Nick to you I know I know I know I'm
just saying after two weeks I feel like
I'm gonna one-up you
but when I went through I have the
Chargers getting the to see to see I go
to the Super Bowl oh I don't know what's
above that winning in the Super Bowl
never gonna be amazing those rivers
because I'm I think I'm like no rivers a
breeze I think because Drew's in San
Diego that's what you're leaning towards
red stop don't give it a I don't know
but yeah you know I know I've been heavy
on the Saints all offseason you are
super heavy I'm putting the Saints at
least in the final four of the NFC I
know that you can put bring that to the
bank
that will be great though okay on Tong
calm you wanted to do the Wednesday
podcast now that's just some notes that
I wrote down that David Moore kid for
Seattle looks like a pretty good
receiver Mike Williams that catch was
awesome your guy Roisin green popped
again without and a half sacks I'm
curious when a guy like Roisin green he
played 42 snaps I went I checked the
sheet he played the most snaps of anyone
on the team right does that mean
anything no it means that they want to
use him and they want to make sure he's
in real good shape and NFL shape for
week one of the regular season so it
doesn't mean yeah
Isaac Rochelle had two snaps for the
Chargers he played the most snaps for
the Chargers he was like a big defensive
line guy but you came in and you said
that finally Seattle has an offense so a
lot of people like to take shots at
Brian Schottenheimer yeah in fact I
liked
shots at Brian Schottenheimer because he
had the 80th ranked offense in college
football in his last job for Georgia and
then before that it was awful
you have always been a defender of Brian
Schottenheimer yeah what are you seeing
that's getting you excited about Seattle
well I mean for an offense I mean it's
no longer just like let's spread the
field and let russell wilson either
throw a three-step slant or Russell just
dance around and try to make something
happen for us their old line it's got a
chance this year and the biggest reason
it has a chance is because
Schottenheimer has a downhill running
game and he's got more than two to three
run plays in his run game scheme so that
is gonna like that's gonna change their
team dramatically the fact that they're
gonna have a running game early on in
the year that is gonna keep people on
edge Chris Carson looks good but it's
pulling guards it's different schemes
where the last three years it's inside
zone or outside zone let me give you
just my insight because I'm reading all
these books from the analytics community
and so many people say that that's a
little bit of shadow homers downfall is
he gets obsessed with the downhill
running game and he's one of those
people that goes we're gonna run to
establish the pass which is an archaic
mentality it doesn't matter
there's there's proven commodities that
throwing early at first inside down is
better and running later is better right
that's the fear with Schottenheimer
yeah I get it is we're gonna run run run
run run that's not I want Russell Wilson
dumping it off to Chris Carson not
necessarily running yeah why I'd say to
that I hope that Schottenheimer at this
point has realized that man my money man
is number three he is definitely one of
the three best quarterbacks in the sport
so yeah we want to run the ball but we
really just want to run the ball so
number three can be number three and it
doesn't have to be him doing nine
cartwheels every time he can actually
throw to a guy on the first read and
throw him open and then he can bail us
out when there's times that need to be
bailed out but yeah the play-action
passing I think you're gonna see more
aggressive structure down the field
passing off the play action and you know
I think you know the receivers are
interesting they're too severs are
interesting and you have
like Thoreau line rate I do I mean what
about it well I mean Dwane Brown a left
tackle sure the pot they got that I
always say his name around the pot chick
poachy
they did they gotta LSU they got him
playing golf pronounce Toronto jerk dad
Brit is a good center
he's always should have been a center
remember early on they had him as a
Gorger went down in this guy no so
that's a little scary
certainly and then Jordan Roos had to
play and that he wasn't that great right
I know and then you got a Fetty at right
tackle which I know is I watched Melvin
a room destroying them both and that's
why they're gonna they're bringing
George Fant over there now to play right
tackle right well one thing we've
learned is the Texas am ultra athletic
offensive tackle don't draft them well
Jake Matthews got another yes I wouldn't
say he is the ultra athletic but I'm
talking about a Leahy and this a Fetty
these are the guys that we made fun of
in the draft member I said because it
looked like they were playing defense in
a basketball game and they're fast
protecting I thought they can learn
something and get technique wise they
become better better players they're
proving that they are not you know weird
way it actually makes me more impressed
with what Johnny Manziel did right
because the knock about Johnny Manziel
was he had three offensive linemen that
are gonna go in the first round and one
of them has passed only one has he has
even been like as good he hasn't been a
top 3 pick know which is where he was
traveled but they're great your Geron
brown did you say him drum brown for the
Seahawks Seahawks he looks like he's
gonna be a big part of course they got
live still wandering man that happened
to Chris Matthews yeah I know
how did Chris Matthews get a hundred
yards receiving in the Super Bowl and
then we never saw no I know it wasn't
Chris Matthews though was it cover him
at Kentucky okay yes yeah it's amazing
it was one of those days but yeah he
never really lasted to anything magic a
Russell Wilson it is a little bit no
doubt okay alright so on Friday we
alluded to it before we are going to
have there's like an hour long it was
getting Steve Steve Rosner who is Chris
Sims is agent I don't think a lot of
people bleach your Puerto happy with it
but oh we wanted to deal with it he was
Lawrence Taylor's D Omega
he was Lawrence Taylor's agent and he
gives stories from Lawrence Taylor
owning strip clubs gambling with Michael
Jordan really could stuff
then we gave him some exercises first he
was Dave gentlemen me and Sims were
representing O'Dell then he was
representing O'Dell he has a very unique
voice he's a good friend of Sims
he is an acquaintance of mine he might
become my friend its if I let him you
know what I mean like I'm kind of a big
deal you know
we did it all wait so rasa it's coming
on Friday I think you guys will really
enjoy it but now offender do you want to
take us through what's changing with
Sims and Lufkin yeah I'll talk a little
and then you guys can chime in whose are
part of the spreadsheets that Josh has
been doing all this it's all on the
spreadsheets so as of today on Twitter
and Instagram if you're following us
there we're gonna have a new logo this
is a big deal we got a lot of stuff
coming up for football season and we
figured it was time we've had the same
logo for a couple years now we got a new
show that's gonna be premiering
Wednesday September 5th still gonna get
three podcasts a week yes but then
there's gonna be a fourth Sims and left
go show every week which is gonna be our
main show on YouTube in the BR app on
Facebook and it's gonna be awesome yeah
talk a bit more about it yes so this is
the breakdown of the the podcast so
right now we're doing two right we they
come out pretty much Monday night and
Wednesday night but you guys get them in
your feets Tuesday morning Thursday
that's going to stay the same we're
still gonna recap games on Monday and
I'll come out Tuesday morning we're
still gonna have our Wednesday will
record Wednesday dive that's where we're
gonna go into Sims us notebook and give
you guys Nuggets that's gonna come out
Thursday on Thursday we're gonna do our
gambling show that will come out Friday
for you guys but our big new addition is
this YouTube show so this is not gonna
be in your podcast streams but it will
be as federic said in the BR app and on
YouTube and I on Facebook you said -
Facebook - yep this is gonna be like a
round twenty minute show where if we're
covering football on the pods we're kind
of talking the culture of football in
the show really good guests really fun
things we're gonna do we're gonna teach
Sims memes we're gonna have we're gonna
have a shrine to Aaron Rodgers behind us
all the things that you guys have been a
part of on the show legs and ass Aaron
Rodgers
Shanahan we're just we're doing it on
video and it's gonna be a lot of fun and
that's where I think it's gonna take the
next level but let us know what you
think about the logos to their Ivan
they're cool I just changed it on
Twitter just did it let me see can I
look
yeah absolutely and I put the picture
with chatting T oh that's awesome
looks good I like it how you feel good
you have anything that no I mean I when
I just see great art like our new look
or new graphics I asked there's only two
people I care that's Danielle and
Charlotte
oh they approved did they like they did
like are we getting your kids on the
podcast before their games they've been
asking let Philip have been asking I
know I know I need to show everybody
what a bad father I am once again it's
crazy I love it guys you are awesome
week three of the pre season starts
Thursday night with Eagles Browns very
excited to see that and this is the big
week of preseason so Sims we'll be
watching I'll be watching we'll recap it
on Monday as much as we can and then
Wednesday is going to be our big time
season preview awards division winners
we're gonna go through all the teams all
the divisions and and we're gonna have
fun with it yeah now I'm gonna beat you
again and again possibly last year that
was for Sims he's at home for Fentress
good evening and the lef koe man will
holler at you later
see you guys